come back to this [ __ ] you're like nah i
almost got into a fight on the movie
creed set
really yeah with the one with tony bella
the
guy oh the fighter a pretty boxer yeah
it was funny because
i was getting a fight it was a long day
i'll tell you true story so i talked to
malik being in crete
oh yeah out the english fighters
yeah so we have all you know i love you
heavyweights you would have got [ __ ]
up yeah he's a heavyweight values a
monster well i i was bigger back then i
don't care
you were bigger backfield you got
amateur record of four and seven
okay this guy is a monster okay well
he's huge well hold on now yeah
he was he well he's a heavyweight right
yeah world champion dude well i'm sorry
yeah all right well he was fresh off
he's the real deal well he was fresh off
the adonis stevenson lost let's just get
that out the way
okay so he's he's not he's not you know
he apparently he's beatable
look so it's a long day stevenson he's
beatable
yeah well i i mean i got a little
haitian so what yeah why are you trying
to do why would you bring a basketball
we gotta fight tomorrow hey go go go to
the go to the glamour shot head shot
dude
yeah that's a good thing no not that one
not that one this one the top one the
top
that one's ridiculous the top one this
one yeah oh
damn hey i hate when you take head shots
and then it's like yo okay i want you to
put your arm right here
and then just literally yeah just
serious i'm like i'm trying to go to the
one where he has the weight in his hand
and someone's directing them yeah yeah
that's the one right there
look how big look how big look at the
legs legs okay look at the legs there
bigger
tiny what yeah that kind of i mean it's
still a little tiny but i mean you got
something
no who's like hey reach reach for that
and then just pause reach for it and
then it looks like a shakeaway
infomercial that never quite yeah it
looks just every time and it's so weird
every time i have a photo shoot there's
always dudes there's no women that's
just like yo
i think there's a reason for that yeah
what was that for you
that was a chicken donation i mean a
turkey uh i said chicken chicken
that can i use your slippers to go out
real fast they're all baggy
it was thanksgiving it's my thanksgiving
outfit yeah
yeah this is so funny was it was this
for boxing
nah this is a turkey giveaway it was in
nicholson gardens and i was like
that dude on the right looks like a real
stickler with the turkeys
that's enough of this isn't it you
already got one one in the family
don't repeat okay all right listen this
is tall
so you know why yeah no it's just a
donation nicholson gardens and they uh
they they were out there protecting you
know security gets crazy over there oh
god so they was like oh man yeah
i was in creed but anyways so i uh
it was doing a set of we already saw
that video look at that
yeah i was big back then um all right so
we're going to set a creed right
and the studios are there mgm the head
studios it's a long day speaking of 14
hours
so ryan coogler the director he'll do
like these weird spots where he'll watch
playback
and this time he's underneath the ring
right so he's underneath the ring no one
can see him but he's yelling out he
tells tony bellow
hey man i need you to sell those body
shots and he's like selling so
if it looks like he's i'm saying it and
tony's in in the ring with michael b
jordan it's the main scene
and everyone's tired and they're trying
to alternate the ending and we're just
like
over it so i'm like oh [ __ ] he's like
man i heard you i said alternate them
body shots because ryan is like
mad as hell so after the scene tony
bellow we cut and all that i'm chilling
you know i'm talking to the extras you
know i'm chopping it up
all right he goes hey muller don't ever
[ __ ] tell me to sell a body shot i
know how to [ __ ] tell a body shot i
was oh he getting on somebody let me see
so he goes no i'm [ __ ] talking to you
i said me
he said yeah i'll probably say [ __ ] he's
like i heard like he's going off
i'm like man [ __ ] you i said it just
like that it was the hype with the high
boy
that's how you knew i didn't want that
problem
so he goes he goes literally so he's
right right in front of me so i'm
shouting up
he's he's in the ring i'm down he goes
out the ring
go he could have jumped down and like
mauled me right yeah but he wasn't gonna
mow me
he went down and he turned and then he
made this big commotion
and there's a holding them back on the
back and uh there's like matt let's just
say malik to the trailer i'm like what
i'm good
literally the people called the press
they called the police the fans because
the extras they was like oh man we love
malik he's about to get killed
right damn literally at that point huh
keep going i'm fine
okay so i'm in the trailer and we had to
be separated the whole time the whole
thing damn the whole
day then the police though the guy named
nicholas starting the
uh the producer he comes and gives me
he's like yo malik the cops are here
uh they want to know if you want to
press charges okay what i was like for
what i was about to beat him up
it was like let's be like listen
let's be real here let's be real here do
you want to practice enough with the
joke
yeah exactly so i had to sit down and
talk to the police
it was two guys there what a bunch of
[ __ ] called the cops
who called the cops uh tony bellew
probably can be on a lot of hollywood
sets if that's your
if that's the way you act oh you're
gonna put up with that not exactly and
he was like but he was the main star
and really we had to go through separate
vans on the way back to the
we stayed in the same hotel here's my
question andre ward hold on before i say
that andre ward he comes back he's so
this is the funny part of story
so i'm riding i'm in i'm in the front
seat so i got security and all that
right
and andre ward goes hey yo i look back
he's like yo
how does it feel when you know you about
to get your ass whipped and you still
survive
i said funny i said it feels pretty good
there it is andre he was like yeah keep
your hands up what's yours
the man oh yeah i love him yeah so you
you were gonna like if he would have
came at you you have to try to hang
yourself you had to yeah yeah but it's
not like you just
you don't know yeah i know how to try it
exactly but the fact that it was just a
long day like he was saying it's 14 hour
days and ryan coogler would do these
weird stuff but that's why he's he just
tries
we shot that scene literally for four
days four days that same exact scene oh
did that movie do well
yeah we didn't recreate it
really well creature didn't do as well
but it was still pretty good
that's good we had the screen test and
michael b jordan
asked me out the movie they're
apparently like we're all set on uh
malik
causing problems
but what's crazy is like a lot of
big-time actors cause a lot of problems
and people put up with it until they eat
[ __ ] at the box office and then you're
out i think you get two strikes
like martin lawrence was unfortunately
known for just being a dick really what
yep martin lawrence
really yeah hmm but uh
yeah he was like he like he would come
with the entourage he'd come up he'd
come late
he demanded a full basketball court and
like all these demands wherever they're
at
oh really it was just real difficult to
deal with and as soon as you bomb
then hollywood's like we're good hey i
love knight's tale
or black knight was it black man i got
you i'm with you yeah
everybody have you seen it with a few
guys
yeah butler uh oh really
for a while but then he got sober and
now he's better
is another one katherine was a big one
who was it catherine heigl she was
eight she didn't knock up and then we
did an interview talking [ __ ]
about uh judd apatow and like all the
boys on
on that even she says rogan she was
difficult to deal with
name another movie she's like she hasn't
been in [ __ ] oh megan
fox too she called michael bay hitler
and he like black balder
all the time like they're not gonna put
you know listen megan
fox is smoking but there's a lot of hot
girls see him at the audition
yeah so it's like all right we'll move
on someone else oh they're not going to
put up with people they're difficult
you see at these auditions you see the
usual suspects so you just have one time
to mess up
and they waiting in the wind like come
on baby
yeah literally same with stand up though
there's some guys who you talk to
the managers like oh we we wouldn't have
them back oh yeah like the managers of
the
i love there's nothing better when we
get there it's like friday late show and
the manager comes in like how the show's
going like good how
have you been like yeah we're all right
you know
look at what happened and then they'll
tell you a nightmare story i love it oh
they'll be dropping them names
oh yeah it's the best they'll be
dropping them names about who
yeah some some comics will won't they
won't let the manager talk to him direct
they have to go through somebody else
they won't even look
they'll be like can you get me a coke
and the waiter's right there but they
only talk to this person
it's weird but but also there are some
crazy
club owners um yeah
kind of not really most of them are
pretty stable there's some morons out
there but most of them are pretty stable
especially the big dogs yeah the big the
big ones are good they're solid
like family like family owned they run a
tight ship
and then some i mean there's some we
could i don't name them but there's
something yeah i want an eight-month
so i went to one club i didn't see the
manager the whole weekend
yeah the waitress came up and paid me
yeah
he did she said here's your check and i
was like oh
yeah okay
some are weird some of the clubs are
poorly ran yeah that's the worst
yeah how about that when i get off stage
at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son